j'imaginais de fines aussi mais bon j'ai
vite vu que jean-michel et delphine ça
allait pas le faire j'ai donné pour
roger waite vous aimez bien benjamin
sinon oui oui j'ai bien aimé va inciter
à ce que si vous n'étiez pas avec roger
vous auriez peut avoir une aventure et
benjamin et vous demande tous les jeunes
la table en fait non mais dis que la
vérité
non pas du tout pas du tout non pas du
tout pour quel motif
benjamin pas dit trop juillet un
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
teenager quang vinh pour moi dit la
vérité
non mais alors physiquement un maxime
c'est plus mon stylo débat là le droit
c'est pas avec roger allam achiou play
on est on est dans sur un douce
important concours des centres de
baballe hockey à choisir non c'est vous
n'étiez pas avec roger vous auriez pu
avoir une aventure avec maxime en
laponie chuter ce serait plus maxime mon
style non mais ça me regarde et on
cherchait pas de relation la porte
demain
parce qu'en plus les huiles essentielles
ça me dérange absolument pas j'en ai pas
retouché mais là aussi on à la fois qu
un maximum
est-ce que ça pour être beau style de
finale totalement et même auriez pu sens
pécho vous aurez une grande discussion
entre les deux on a appris à se
connaître à rêves présentant de très
profond ouais et puis j'ai appris
qu'elle était en couple est content que
ça monte coûté en tout cas elle fait ce
que j'ai vu en laponie que vous allez
voir grand et je voudrais remercier la
personne qui est autour de la table de
nous avoir autorisés à diffuser cette
amitié naissante le répète c'est que de
l'amitié
non mais c'est vrai c'est de l'amitié ça
n'a rien à voir avec une relation
inverse ex ou quoi que ce soit il faut
vous le dis il ne s'est rien passé
accor va faire vous dire les choses et
platonique excusez moi voulait pas les
voir
je n'en peux plus
tout roule avec les libéraux tchèques là